the marvel cinematic universe is a
moving target for all the ways in which
kevin feige has made the entire
operation as streamlined and
consistent as possible there will always
be ways in which the apple cart is upset
if not overturned entirely the
incredible hulk is largely forgotten
from canon
terence howard was replaced with don
cheadle in the role of roadie after iron
man
and ant-man's original director edgar
wright who spent years working to make
sure that character got his own big
budget movie
was booted from his passion project and
to replace with peyton reed no matter
how many years pass there will always be
unexpected changes that leaves fans
scratching their heads
and while most fans rightly assume there
would be a third ant-man movie
what they didn't anticipate was that a
key character would be recast
we know that the third ant-man movie is
entitled ant-man and the wasp
quantomania we know that both paul rudd
and evangeline lily are reprising their
roles as scotland and hope van dyne
we also know that veteran actors michael
douglas and michelle pfeiffer
are returning as hank pym and janet van
dyne so naturally we all assume that
scotland's daughter cassie lang
would still be played by avengers and
game actor emma furman
however we recently discovered that
cassie lang has been recast with an
arguably more well-known actor
and boy howdy do fans ever have some
strong opinions about that news
emma furman is out as cassie lang and in
her stead
the role will be played by freaky star
catherine newton we don't know why the
casting change happened
nor do we know what the change will mean
for the ant-man franchise or for cathy
lang specifically
thurmond has not gone on record about
the recast other than by removing cassie
lang from an instagram bio
newton posted the news to instagram
writing last night i dreamed of being a
superhero
fans of ant-man are passionate and
conflicted about the news
twitter user jesse pup writes emma
furman was great in the role as cassie
it bothers me how unknown lesser actor
actresses keep getting replaced by
up-and-coming actor actresses
it's almost like they made her role in
end game pointless while thurman was
effectively only in one scene
many fans feel a connection because of
the emotional intensity
of the moment when scott lang returns
from the quantum realm to find he's lost
years of time and that his daughter has
grown up without him in a world ravaged
by thanos
right francisca wait wait the actress
emma fuhrman gave us the best scene of
end game and they recasted her in
ant-man 3
cold people are of course excited about
newton in the role
but it's probably themyscira who said it
best when she wrote
i've been very impressed by catherine
newton and everything i've seen her in
and she does look more like cassie lang
from the comics i do feel bad for emma
furman
kind of sucks to originate her role and
then have it taken from you
there are tons of rumors about the what
where who and how of the mcu's future
but one of the prevailing rumors is that
we're headed towards a young avengers
story one of the members of that team
would just so happen to be a hero named
stature
or as we presently know her cassie lang
in the pages of young avengers
cassie happens to be the pals with
future hawkeye kate bishop
as we know kate bishop is being played
by haley steinfeld
in the upcoming disney plus hawkeye
series so there's a very solid chance
that the mcu will pair the two
characters together
in the future what makes the information
relevant to the casting of cassie lang
is that catherine newton already has a
solid track record as a physical
performer
recently we saw her play a very violent
serial killer in the body swap horror
comedy freaky
however it's also worth noting that she
also played claire novak a hunter on the
long-running cw series supernatural
actors can always train to become action
stars but it's probably not a
coincidence that when marvel recast
cassie lang
they did so with an actor who already
has action star in her dna
ant-man in the wasp quantum mania begins
filming in 2021
and is currently set to release
theatrically in 2022
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
single one